und sie haben sich das ganz bestimmt
anders vorgestellt eigentlich wollten
jan und melanie heinrich die welt
umsegeln das junge paar ist seit monaten
jetzt aber in panama sitzt dort fest
aufgrund von kona und steht kurz vor dem
finanziellen kollaps
jetzt haben sie nur noch einen wunsch
endlich wieder zurück nach hause nach
deutschland zu kommen
sie wollten um die ganze welt segeln und
sitzen nun in der falle
melanie und jan heinrich aus
markkleeberg in der nähe von leipzig
dann bei instagram kann man die reise
der beiden von beginn an verfolgen aber
seit einiger zeit gibt es da nichts
neues mehr zu sehen denn sie sitzen fest
vor panama gegen korona fast 100 tage
schon warten sie nun und dürfen nicht
weiter am ausgang des panamakanals
gestrandet vor über einem jahr gaben der
produktionsleiter und die kita chefin
ihre wohnung auf und auch den job
kauften sich dieses 13 meter lange boot
für 100.000 euro
und dann ging es los auf die reise um
die welt aber dann kam panama und erst
mal durften sie nicht mehr raus aus dem
hafen und an land gehen dürfen sie auch
nicht jetzt hängen sie auf einer
nachbarinsel fest sie gelten dort als
corona risiko in eine post vom
zwanzigster april schreiben die beiden
vor einem jahr dachten wir wir hätten
uns gut vorbereitet und dann alle
eventualitäten gedacht jetzt liegt der
pazifik vor uns aber wir können und
dürfen nicht weiter wenn die grenzen
bald nicht öffnen da brauchen wir einen
plan b endet unsere reise hier in panama
inzwischen ist es drei monate her dass
sie das letzte mal einkaufen waren in
einem supermarkt da ist improvisieren
angesagt sie haben obst an ihr beiboot
bestellt und machen allerlei wie brot
und joghurt selbst damit es nicht
langweilig wird hat melanie inzwischen
ein online studium begonnen und wir
wollen nur mit beiden sprechen denn
normalerweise sagt man oh wie schön ist
panama wenn man diese geschichte aber
hört geht man davon aus die situation
sieht bei ihnen jetzt ganz anders aus ja
ja wir sind jetzt mehr als 100 tagen in
panama und panama ist sehr schön aber
für uns ist hacken
schöner käfig sozusagen ein schöner
käfig also gibt es jetzt immer öfter die
momente von verzweiflung weil man eben
so weit weg ist von familie freunden von
seinem alltag ja gut wir unser plan war
ja um die welt zu segeln sind letztlich
in deutschland in ost- realos gesiegelt
und von daher schon geplant dass wir
länger von der familie weg sind aber
jetzt hier festzustecken ist natürlich
entgegen unserer player und das ist
natürlich dann frustrierend dass man
nicht weiter kommt und es kam aber
irgendwann der punkt wo alle gesagt
haben jetzt macht es dann sehen und
jetzt müssen wir schauen dass wir in
keiner weise die reise abbrechen und das
pro tier verkaufen und dann zurück nach
deutschland kommen wenn es möglich ist
es gab neulich eine rückflug aktion von
panama sieger privat organisiert
organisiert mehrere europäer hatten sich
zusammengeschlossen wussten sie davon
oder hatten sie nicht irgendwie die
chance sich denen auch anzuschließen und
zurück zu kommen
ja wir wussten von dieser rückholaktion
auch schon vorher gab's flüge
organisiert von der von der deutschen
botschaft oder im auswärtigen amt und es
gibt auch immer wieder flüge von
europäischen ländern
aber wir wollen halt unser boot hier
nicht zurücklassen und erstmal versuchen
das portieren panama zu verkaufen
nur wenn das jetzt nicht klappt in den
nächsten wochen hängt dann müssen wir
halt öl sauren apfel beißen das buch ihr
land bringen und dann versuchen wir zu
so einer humanitäre rückholaktion in
europa zu kommen wir hier in deutschland
auch in vielen anderen teilen von europa
hat man langsam das gefühl normalität
kehrt ein stück weit zumindest zurück
haben sie also nicht vielleicht darüber
nachgedacht diese zeit jetzt in panama
auszusitzen und dann anschließend mit
ihrem plan weiter um die welt zu segeln
vorzufahren
ja gut das problem an der sache ist dass
der pazifik vor uns liegt und es immer
bestimmte songs gibt denen man durch den
pazifik segeln kann und in anderen
zeiten dann die gefahr von zitronen oder
hurricanes besteht
und dieses wetterfenster dass das
schließlich halt jetzt oder hat sich
schon so gut wie geschlossen und das
würde dann bedeuten dass wir noch mal
ein komplettes jahr hier bis nächstes
jahr an früher warten müssten ist
verdammt unsere reise vom vom wetter her
dann auch weiter fortführen könnten und
das ist uns einfach zu lange zu warten
und das auch würde den die zeit den
zeitlichen rahmen den wir uns gesetzt
haben sie die reise dann überschreiten
dieses gespräch mit jan o melanie
heinrich haben wir bereits vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet wir wünschen
natürlich alles gute und hoffen dass sie
jetzt schnellstmöglich zurück nach
deutschland kehren können